Hey, it's David sped. I'm here to answer the internet in one take.
That was good.
Would you rather give the first 90% of a or the last 10
I'm giving the blow job? You're like see internet.
They want to know.
So the first nine seconds or the last one second,
that's me. Uh, I guess the first 90 seems a little less messy.
You get to choose between a sum of money or world peace. Um, I,
I know which one I'm heading towards already.
How much does that sum of money need to be in order for you not to choose world
peace? This one's too dense. I don't quite follow it. Uh,
I do. I need a lot of money, so, uh, I, I have to pick world.
I have to pick world peace. No, I don't want to,
whatever. What if someone watched this? I'm not worried about that though. Uh,
if every time you finish sex, always acts a song played,
which would it, which would you want it to be a
wishy Davy spade due to, to DC?
Would you rather have your mom? Yeah,
don't bring my model. Would you rather have your mom,
which fourth grader wrote these? Is that you? Nope. That's him. Don't push in.
You'll be embarrassed.
You have to have your mom send you a nude or send all your friends. A nude. Oh,
sent all my F I thought you said send a note to my mom. Your mom sends you one,
or you send one to all your friends. You send nudes.
There's a stock one that goes out a lot
except Chris Browns.
[inaudible] but I tell you what it gets a lot of bites,
I guess. Uh,
I'll S I'll take my best one incentive to my friends.
You can only watch one movie, the rest of your life, Tommy boy,
your black sheep. Shh. You know,
the split on this and out in the real world is probably 90% like Tommy
Baltimore. It's a black sheep, but black sheep does get some props out there.
But I feel like
I might even pick box just because I don't see it as much. I see Tommy boy,
all it's always listen. You can see me any day of the week on TBS at 3:00 PM.
One of my 19 things is flying on it.
Would you rather lose a leg or never have sex again? Oh,
if I lost that middle leg, I could never have again.
Oh, are you okay? Would you rather always wear high heels or a belly shirt? Oh,
I have a bad back, but I have a worst stomach. Uh
[inaudible] I would say belly shirt, just because of my back.
This is horrible for whoever's walking around with me.
Just take your leg off with that. All right. 500 more.
If you could have one person narrate play by play of you having sex,
it would it be Al Michaels is first and then maybe Bob Manary,
you know, Bob mattering is funny. Okay. Okay. All Michaels
I go, huh?
What's the one thing a person can say or do that makes you immediately hate
them? Um, like me back
that's the best we can with that one.
I don't think so.
If you could fight one person to death and switch lives with them,
if you win, who would you fight? Uh,
and I have to fight a girl though, cause I want to win, you know,
just maybe Tina Fey. She's fun.
She's smart, smart writer. And I just saw her yesterday. So just came to mind.
All right, Tina, look out [inaudible].